Europe is actually seriously scary China
is in fact seriously scary although it
gets it's harder to track but it has
less press but and we are not an island
I think with international
interdependence can be overstated but
you really would not expect us to be
doing to be completely immune to these
bad developments and we that solid a
basis here so here we are six years
after Lehman fell still very fragile
let's talk about Europe first what's the
problem in Europe
well it's interesting that's shifted it
was originally oh there's trouble in the
debtor countries and you know but it's
very strong Germany but now their
problem is that after years and years of
not of being worried about the wrong
thing being too worried about debt being
worried about inflation which never came
now they suddenly look around and they
discover that they've turned into Japan
without the social cohesion that
inflation is practically zero
it doesn't matter zero is now yeah but
they're essentially a deflationary trap
already Germany is slowing down sharply
because it depends upon exports and more
- yeah and and it's just it's looking
and they don't have I think the through
the scary thing is they don't have tools
here as people you know your Penn
Central Bank America drawn here physical
tools yeah monetary tools got a good man
smart guy running the ECB but there's
only so much you can do
fiscal tools hard in any cases because
there's no common government and nothing
can happen without the Germans and the
Germans are not ready to change their
tune and by the time everybody wakes up
to the gravity of the situation Europe
may be deeply stuck in a kind of
permanent depression with God knows what
political consequences so that's a very
very frightening pressure from the right
pressure from the this is why these
things were right and left meat right
the anti-immigrant groups had extreme
nationalist groups if we say what if
marine lepen anti-immigrant what if she
becomes president of france and you say
oh that's not gonna happen but if you
believe the polls that what happened
then the president's today that's right
if it were the election were held today
was be a real possibility you kept in
Britain Golden Dawn in Greece
the separatists in northern Italy
there's a lot simmering because that's
what year after year of economic failure
does